obi chien gentil je sais de l'être vous
êtes un agent fédéral impliqué dans un
programme secret du fbi est
officieusement le gouvernement des états
unis élimine des civils innocents sous
prétexte de protéger la démocratie
qui donne les ordres le directeur du fbi
j'arrête fait preuve d'un peu de
reconnaissance si tu veux avoir une vie
normale
j'arrête maintenant
où est ma famille
si je découvre que tu as quoi que ce
soit à voir avec la disparition de ma
petite fille il va te falloir plus
d'hommes
[Musique]
tu seras mort avant la fin de la journée
tout ce que j'ai fait
je les fais pour toi
je viens gentil
[Musique]
j'essaie de l'être